from food to fashion magic one of the
biggest fashion conventions is back in
las vegas jillian stopped by to check
out the latest summer trends and the
upcoming fall fashions
hey so magic is back here in las vegas
we are back at the convention center and
i found the pink i'm hearing this is one
of the trending colors for the year but
i'm here with a professional jordan the
vice president of magic is here to do
one of my favorite things how to shop
and walk so jordan thanks for having us
again thank you it's great seeing you so
i'm seeing a lot of sparkles around
let's get to it what is trending this
season so you are absolutely right it is
all about bold colors and we are seeing
lots of feathers this time so bring on
the feathers bring on the sparkles bring
on the bold colors particularly pink
lime green and we're seeing lots of
blues and sky blues and i know denim is
big there's even sparkles on the jeans
so i am absolutely loving that and i
could just stay here and be distracted
the whole time but we're going to keep
walking we're going to make our way
through the convention floor so let's
move on over here uh tell us what boot
this is and what we're seeing over here
so this is buy together it's a full
collection they have a little bit of
everything so everything from your
casual look to your more fancy look it
is all about the flare so we are seeing
flares on sleeves we are seeing flares
on denim so everyone wants that puffy
sleeve that flared denim is going to be
the new it's denim coming into 23. let's
talk about shoes so urban cowboy is
still a thing so we're still seeing a
lot of cowboy boots and we're seeing a
lot of platforms they're also tapping
into this cinderella slipper vibe so
you'll see a lot of clear straps a lot
of iridescent clear heels so that will
be very big coming into 23 as well i
just got some cowboy boots so i'm happy
to know that i'm on point
jordan thanks for breaking it all down
for us always so fun to look around and
see what's hot in the fashion world so i
will send it back to you guys